i i will admit i was busy with other
things yesterday i didn't go back and
watch the chief's buccaneers game i'm
not going to pretend that i did it's all
right i defer to you for this today
chris don't worry you watch talking so
closely we can talk about this a lot so
don't there's a lot of things to talk
about here well the game was on at 4 25
p.m eastern as we're getting ready for a
tv show so i didn't watch it closely
thank you for the effort but i saw the
highlights does that matter but uh you
you looked at it more closely talked
yesterday about the misguided effort of
the tampa bay buccaneers to put single
coverage on tyreek hill you took a
closer look at it
why couldn't they stop this guy was it
as simple as there were very few people
not named jaylen ramsey who could cover
tyreek hill right exactly right and you
know there there's a there's the okay we
can put him on an island and then
there's like whoa we're gonna put him on
an island right even like stefan gilmore
in his prime yeah he was on a he was on
an island against tyree kill but when it
was man-to-man this safety was still
over in his direction just to scare
mahomes a little bit wait is he helping
him and doubling him oh wait he's still
there i can't throw the goat there was
no presence or help for carlton davis a
little bit now hey the first long
touchdown
that was covered three the out and up
touchdown just like that and that's all
on carlton davis and just that hey that
it's tyree kill it's patrick mahomes let
them have the eight yard out route
that's not your job to stop that there's
underneath coverage that needs to get
there don't bite on that he bites on
that you know then
tampa got caught into a little bit
because this is where mahomes and
company have changed you know we've
talked about a lot where the teams that
drop back and play zone and keep them to
stop the deep pass plays and all that
that's how to beat them well
kansas city's had so many teams attacked
them like that we've seen now they can
throw the short game just like they did
in the raiders and go ten play drives
and be surgical as good as anybody in
the game now so you can't play that
approach and todd bowles had some
moments where yeah he wanted to get five
rushers blitz and he left carlton davis
in some tough spots um uh you know and
and it's just
it's too much to ask of one guy carlton
davis is a really good football player
but there's got to be an element of
disguise or at least a body presence of
a safety in this type of match-up to at
least scare my homes a little bit and
that's really where they dropped the
ball and didn't make any adjustments
really into the second half where they
started to do some different things
and that's what i'm fascinated by i i
wrote a post yesterday at pft based upon
our seat of the pants discussion
yesterday about the 500 club patrick
mahomes seemed destined to be member
number 19. and ben roethlisberger has
three 500 yard games in his career tom
brady has two drew brees has two
most of the other guys just have one and
there's some strange names on there like
elvis gerbach is in the 500 club yeah
but mahomes eventually will get there
but when you get 362 in the first half
of a game you assume the 138 138 138 is
coming 138 yes 138 is coming in the
second half 138's nothing especially
when you had over 200 in the first
freaking quarter of the same game what
happened in the second half what did the
bucks do differently what did the chiefs
do differently to cause that record pace
to be disrupted yeah well i mean it's
not a whole lot i mean it's not that i
sit here and just go oh my gosh i think
i think tampa got into okay let's stop
wasting our time and blitzing five which
is i have a pet peeve with five man
blitzes because they they don't get home
that much and i want to just go that guy
maybe would have helped on the tyre kill
touchdown pass to have a double cover
there they did have some moments of
where they doubled tyree kill dubber
doubled travis kelsey in some certain
obvious passing situations
but you know
still you think about the end of the the
it's 17 nothing the strip sack fumble
they went right down the field you know
this they get the field goal right
before the half the second half they
have one bad drive then they get the
ball they go down and score a touchdown
where he hits the 20-yard pass to tyree
kill
then it wasn't necessarily something
where i looked at and you just go oh
the bucks are doing this or their
dominant the bucks defensive line
started to pressure a little bit
and kansas city just fell into a little
bit of a law a little penalty you know
first down run that didn't get many
yards second and nine and
that that's really all there is there to
be said i can't sit there and tell you
it was some groundbreaking thing you
know kansas said he took his foot off
the gas pedal a little bit got a little
unlucky tampa played a little bit better
but what's amazing about you know kansas
city
pedal go you know foot goes off the
pedal oh wait we need a few first downs
no problem we'll put it back on the
pedal and get that and of course they
make it happen
if they could ever keep the foot on the
pedal for an entire game chris
they could have a thousand yards they
could have a hundred points patrick
mahomes would blow past north van
broglin's single game passing record of
554 yards isn't that amazing in 1951
decades before
they reconfigured the rules to enhance
passing norm van brockman had 554 and
what's even more amazing is he has a
game like that and it takes the nfl 25
years to realize people may like
more of that
than the ground and pound and three
yards in the cloud of dust it took him
25 years to finally understand that
balls flying through the air is more
exciting than guys running in to a scrum
of bodies yeah it is amazing and what's
even more i mean
really
500 yards in that era
in the 70s or 80s like really what's
that worth now what is that worth now i
mean really
it's it's like
i think comparable you'd have to go it's
a 700 yard game like that that's what
that is to me now
and to your point
you know mahomes and hill and every they
left yards on the field i mean he he
could have broke the record the other
day he could have thrown for close to
600 yards he definitely could and you
know to that i wouldn't be surprised if
we see that it's going to be that type
of effort unbelievable first half and he
just needed one or two more plays and
they were very close listen it's 27 to
10. he's got a play-action rpo fake this
is another reason the bucks had to play
man-to-man they had problems with the
rpo issues he's got machole hardman
going up the left seam it's he's wide
there's nobody in the screen it's going
to be a walk-in 80 yard touchdown he
misses him you know so there's that play
there's a few others where you go whoa
he hits that who the hell knows what
happens in this game as far as stats and
everything but uh they're fun to watch
and their offense uh
is it's the best in football of course i
don't care what the stats say you give
me one offense i'm taking them
he'll eventually join the likes of
gerbach and vince ferragamo and others
and phil simms and phil sims boomer
assistant boomer system almost got there
twice matt schaub
in once three yards away from a second
wow uh i don't know they don't give you
a second jacket they just put maybe a
different patch on your jacket if you're
in it twice but yeah mahomes will get
there and maybe he'll break the
long-standing record nearly 70 years old
a 554 set by hall of famer norman van
brocklin all right uh tom brady as
mentioned earlier has two trips to the
500 club
no 500 club trips this year probably
unlikely that there will be any although
he's sliced and diced the vikings
defense pretty much his entire career
maybe his next game will get him to 500
after he has two weeks to get ready for
it who do we blame
that's been
you know the the the topic of
of of candor criticism honesty passive
aggressive from bruce aryan to the point
where tom brady's got to be getting
upset whose fault is it though for what
the buccaneers offense has been through
the first 12 well i
i i don't want to like blame there
there's still to me it looks like a
clash of cultures here there really is
you know for me well what i see and just
being what's said here
you know could brady be better
definitely could the bucks maybe be
better and how they talk to the media as
a head coach and you know what they're
doing offensively to make brady more
comfortable yeah i i'm sure they can be
better you know
there's
there's two things that jump out here
you know first off to me mike hey bruce
arians made some comments yesterday
about getting the ball to ronald jones
more you know i believe tampa wants to
play the game of we'd like to run the
ball
keep gronk in the game cameron breit
from time to time we get two tight ends
but always have a tight end
and either two tight ends and two
receivers or one tight end and three
receivers and we want to keep the run
the ball and keep the ability to be
aggressive passing the ball down the
football field
i think that's what that's what left
witch and bruce aryans do
but i also know tom brady wanted antonio
brown like i know that that's him i've
been told by too many people i know in
the business that brady is the reason
antonio brown's there which tells me he
wants to spread it out and do the
shotgun stuff and all of that that's
fine but bruce arians and byron leftwich
aren't mcdaniels and bill belichick they
don't have nine zillion ways to throw
the ball six and seven yards to where
brady likes it so that's the the issues
and then i think the other issue you
could throw onto this mic for me
is tom brady has a pressure problem he
has a pressure problem when people blitz
him this year our people are around him
he's just not good he panics he can't
move at all and he doesn't move in the
pocket as well as he used to and it's
not because he can't move it's just like
he doesn't do it as much
but either way that's what jumps out to
me and when you miss the first
four third downs of the game that were
all third and six or less
i mean i don't know you're you're in a
good position third down to quarterback
down you gotta make it happen and there
that was really the issues early on in
the football game then the two
interceptions guess what mike
blitz right panic just throw it up oh
gosh you know and a few of these guys
aren't even close and he's doing it so
that to me is also the issue a clash of
cultures and then brady is not
performing well right now under pressure
or with people around him and that's
leading to some you know stale moments
for their offense
remember the first time we noticed that
it was against the steelers in
pittsburgh a couple of years ago yeah
where he bailed out and he claimed he
was throwing the ball out of bounds and
he got picked off i mean that's when he
really embraced the live to fight
another day mantra where he will bail
out as he's throwing the ball or get rid
of the football prematurely the throw to
julian edelman last year against the
chiefs while the game was still in doubt
frank clark bearing down on tom brady
tom brady does the throw it and duck and
cover in one motion and it's an
inaccurate throw i mean when you're
thinking about avoiding getting blown up
by the guy who's coming straight at you
you're more likely to throw in an
accurate pass and i think we're seeing
that and this gets back to the watch the
legs not the arm yeah the arm in perfect
laboratory conditions will continue to
be there into his 50s the legs are what
will betray him and he literally is
being chased around by guys half his age
yeah no doubt and and at a certain point
at a certain point you utter the line
made famous by danny glover in the
original lethal weapon movie i can't
remember where i'm too old for this
although
exactly yeah at some point at some point
that is what you feel that is what you
believe and that is when you say i've
had enough and you have to wonder
whether those thoughts are starting to
creep in he plans to make it to 45 he's
already made it to 43.
does he make it to 44. well i don't know
i don't know i i mean listen he can
still throw the ball he's still got a
special arm
and you can still win and really be good
with tom brady i don't have any doubts
with that i i don't but to like what
you're saying
you know yeah he can't move and he's in
preservation mode he is 43.
so you have to expect realistically
that yes he's gonna have moments of oh
wait um there's i feel like i'm getting
pressure and i'm gonna throw a ball off
my back foot even though okay nobody's
really close or you know overreacting to
somebody about to hit him and then you
overreact so hard that you throw the
ball into the helmet of the defensive
player and it pops up in the air and
there's an interception you know that
that's to be expected at 43. you know
you said it the legs
and to me the next thing you always look
at is the willingness to stand in there
and get hit and brady for 43 is still
willing but the other thing that's going
to me where
and again brady can win and you can be
good
there's no doubt but like the excuse
making for tom brady throughout tv right
now is ridiculous it's ridiculous it's
gone to another level it's going back to
i feel like a few years ago with like
the eli manning conversation if you give
them the best offensive line and the
best receivers and the best defense and
the best coaches and the best running
backs you can still win
wha i mean well damn oh great well let
me play then because we can win two
i'll play let me play that mike florio
play right and that's where i just hear
this bs that just drives me crazy right
now
um
as it gets back to the offense and
because one of the things we've heard
from bruce arians the idea that tom
brady is the offense he's picking the
plays he's calling the plays he's saying
what he wants but he's not involved in
the play design that's the thing he's
limited by the menu you go to a
restaurant they give you a menu agreed
what you want to eat may not be on the
menu is that the problem here what he
wants to eat isn't on the menu i think
so a little bit right this is where the
no off season and then maybe having
another off season together could really
help them because he can really get in
meeting rooms with them to go like hey
we're missing these nine or ten plays in
our empty sets that they got a lot of
rules and i know it was too hard to
coach them or put them in our offense
with the way this year was
and yeah that's what i've been trying to
argue you know one the team is not built
to be hey edelman amendola wes welker
six and five yards mike evans isn't that
guy he's not chris godwin is really not
that guy either he can do a little of
that antonio brown has an aspect of that
but that's not the way this offense was
formulated so player-wise it's not ready
for the spread it out dink and dunk and
then
then play-wise it's also
not ready to be able to deliver that to
brady and just go okay be surgical and
nor i'm just with the other thing we
need to keep an eye for
is do they want to do that does bruce
arians really want to bend to brady and
and leftwich ben de brady to play an
offense that really they don't really
believe in or never really have great
experience uh in either and that's i
think going to be something to watch out
for as we finish the season and go in
the next year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports